noch von vertrauen
doch sag mal wie man eine prüfung hat
mir davon erzählt ich bin angenommen
wächst man nicht wirklich glücklich
was ist dann muss erinnert mich nicht
abgeholt ich hätte ich abholen können
wenn ich gewusst hätte aber wenn lesben
denn ist mein freund irgendwie wir haben
uns im internet kennengelernt
seit einem halben jahr haben wir täglich
kontakt er kommt aus köln weißt du das
der grund warum du hierher gezogen ist
nein natürlich nur wegen des studiums
naja vielleicht ein bisschen aber weißt
du nach brasilien kann wenn nicht kommen
dafür hatte nicht genug geld
er arbeitet im theater naja und habe ich
mir gedacht wenn ich schon in
deutschland studieren will sein warum
dann nicht in der schönen domstadt in
der stadt aus der eine
internet-bekanntschaft kommt man ja das
ist doch total bescheuert du kannst dir
doch überhaupt nicht natürlich kenne ich
ihn wie denn wenn du noch nie getroffen
hast öffnen seien e-mails aus seinen
fotos und fahr aufpassen georgia
vielleicht ist das ein einen spinner ein
perverser ein verrückter mädchen blind
in die arme
dass sie noch nicht mit ihm getroffen
oder aber heute heute treffe ich ihn da
bin ich mal gespannt
ich hoffe du kommst leben zurück die
vier frauen seit unfassbar wenn er ex
freundin wollte auch immer auf die
kunsthochschule als ob du einen diplom
braucht ein künstler zu sein
künstler wie sieht es denn mit dem essen
aus künstler genau
wenigstens habe ich noch träume träumen
ich habe auch träume und zwar vom essen
man gibt es denn was wenn du gekocht
hast wenn du wenigstens irgendwelche
pläne für deine zukunft hättest du doch
mal nach wenn wir mal was essen willst
ja dann ging einkaufen ich hab keine
lust ist immer alleine zu machen nicht
linoleum durch teppich ersetzt wird
endet und da haben uns